all right tonight sadly brand new
information about the jihadist that
attacked New York City by using a rented
pickup truck mowing down innocent people
on a bike path now authorities are now
revealing new details about this Isis
inspired attack let's take a look it
appears that mr. Stay Puft had been
planning this for a number of weeks he
did this in the name of Isis and along
with the other items recovered at the
scene was some notes that further
indicate that he appears to have
followed almost exactly 280 the
instructions that Isis has put out in
its social media channels before with
instructions to their followers on how
to carry out such an attack I told you I
suspected that last night again it's
true catherine herridge her own
catherine herridge reporting the suspect
did not show any remorse during an
interrogation with authorities and
another report says the terrorist is now
boasting and is said to be quote proud
of this attack also tonight there are
reports that the Mazdas terrorist
attended in Paterson New Jersey was
previously under surveillance by the New
York Police Department in the mid-2000s
this is beyond disturbing but
unfortunately it is not surprising we
have seen these types of attacks take
place time and time again why because
people on the Left Democrats liberals
gutless politicians refused to take the
necessary actions from stopping this
from happening in the first place we'll
have more on that in a second but first
the president is responding to this
terror attack and he's calling for
tougher measures to keep the American
people safe isn't that what's most
important including ending the diversity
Visa Lottery program that there's
radical islamists he used to enter the
country take a look at this my
administration is coordinating closely
between federal and local officials to
investigate the attack and to further
investigate this animal who did the
attacking I'm going to ask Congress to
immediately
initiate work to get rid of this program
diverse eree and diversity lottery
diversity lottery sounds nice it's not
nice it's not good this man that came in
or whatever you want to call him brought
in with him other people and he was a
point he was the point of contact the
primary point of contact for and this is
preliminary 23 people that came in or
potentially came in with him and that's
not acceptable so we want to get rid of
chain migration I would certainly
consider that send him to Gitmo
I would certainly consider that look
it's very simple what we are demanding
is merit-based immigration we want
people that are gonna help our country
we want people that are going to keep
our country safe diversity Visa Lottery
and then he brought in 23 others we knew
nothing about him now the White House is
also saying that they can treat this she
hottest as an enemy combatant I agree
with this watch this question does the
president believe this suspect should be
classified as an enemy combatant
I believe we would consider this person
to be in it enemy combatant yes also the
president rightly blasted the Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer on Twitter
he wrote quote the terrorists came into
our country through what is called the
diversity Visa Lottery program hey Chuck
Schumer beauty I want merit-based
meaning merit-based immigration the
president is right the diversity Visa
Lottery program all that was Chuck
Schumer's stupid idea and the Department
of Homeland Security has confirmed that
the radical Islamist in fact used that
program to enter our country in 2010 and
as you just heard the president say this
terrorist was the point of contact for
23 more people that have or may have
come into this country now Senator Chuck
Schumer this was back in 1990 when he
was a congressman he introduced the bill
creating this diversity Visa Lottery to
allow immigrants to flow into the
country now Schumer's proposal
eventually became part of a larger
immigration package that was passed into
law and back in 2013 Chuck Schumer was
bragging about what he did now here's
how Radio Liberty quoted him I was the
author of the diversity visa program so
I care about it Schumer said that's
after nine eleven oh one excuse me is
there any chance the terrorists could
get into this country if Schumer didn't
author that bill let me be clear the
odds are so much greater now because of
the program we would be a safer country
if it weren't for this program maybe
those people would be alive today in
2006 we have a Government Accountability
Office report that actually warned about
terrorists and other bad actors
exploiting this visa program
congratulations Chuck Schumer your
brilliant idea to be more inclusive it
may have contributed to Americans losing
their lives and being injured in New
York City yesterday and I have a
question for the liberal senator where
your tears now Chuck this is something
you should actually be crying about dead
and injured New Yorkers you're a New
York senator now regardless of whatever
talking points though this liberal echo
chamber in America is going to be
spewing about all this there is nothing
that says America has to take in anybody
from any country
foreigners have no right to come here it
is a privilege and president Trump and
Congress are well within their
constitutional authority to restrict
access of whoever they see fit to come
into the country this look there's no
way to ascertain what is in the hearts
of mind of people who want to enter this
country do they want to bring us harm or
not bring us harm do they bring say if
they grow up in a country that
persecutes women and Christians and Jews
and kill lays and lesbians are they
bringing those cultural mores with them
that's why the president is now calling
for a common-sense approach we need now
badly extreme betting especially from
these countries with these deplorable
human rights records abuse of women gays
lesbians Christians Jews it's horrible
we need extreme vetting from societies
and cultures that conflict with our
constitutional freedoms and values the
bottom line we need to know for sure who
is coming into this country and if we're
not a hundred percent sure sorry
American safety comes first now you
wouldn't welcome somebody into your
house would you let them eat dinner with
your family if you knew nothing about
them I don't think you would so why
shouldn't the same standard apply to our
country now the current system the
Democrats are trying to defend is beyond
stupid they're not protecting the
American people it's reckless and it's
creating a very clear and present danger
for you the American people and you have
people like Chuck Schumer they need to
answer this question is immigrant
diversity really more important than the
safety of the American people because at
the end of the day it's that simple do
they care more about letting people into
this country who could cause us harm or
is their first job and responsibility to
protect the American people
now the answer should be obvious but for
many on the Left that is not now take
for example the surveillance of the
mosque that we know literally in this
country there are the them out there
that give rise to radical ideas and
beliefs it's happening inside this
country now we just told you that the
mosque that this terrorist attended was
monitored by the FBI in the early 2000s
but guess what
in comes comrade mayor deblasio of New
York City he shut the program down in de
Blasio actually praised the decision of
himself saying quote this reform is a
critical step forward in easing tensions
between the police and the communities
they serve so that our cops our citizens
can help one another go after the real
bad guys now here's a news flash for the
mayor of New York City
keeping that surveillance program intact
may have prevented a terror attack like
yesterday from ever happening
but the Blasio he doesn't care about
that he's more concerned with being
politically correct because god forbid
we hurt the terrorists feelings god
forbid we risk offending people finding
them those that want to kill us and
destroy us
the mayor's pathetic Chuck Schumer is
pathetic they're both clueless now he
along with Governor Cuomo and other
clueless one in New York are also
shamelessly politicizing this attack
they're going after President Trump they
were asked about gun control by the
liberal media during a press conference
earlier today pretty unbelievable what's
this we support very thorough vetting
not of groups of people just because
they belong to a group we I think this
is a very crucial distinction there
should be very very careful vetting of
anyone where there's an indication of a
concern but not because of their
religion or not because of their country
of origin and there's a much bigger
conversation we could have about gun
safety the NYPD has always rigorously
believed that we need to keep guns out
of this city and the gun safety laws are
here to protect us and protect our
officers the president's tweets I think
we're not helpful I don't think they
were factual I think they tended to
point fingers and politicize the
situation as far as the gun laws I am
increasingly proud that New York State
past some of the smartest gun laws in
the country thus a fact I think it is
madness
the number of assault weapons that we
have in this country I think it in
dangers law enforcement I think it costs
us untold numbers of deaths and I hope
one day we'll have a federal policy that
actually brings sanity to the gun policy
laws in this country oh wait a minute
don't they both have armed guards
constantly 24/7 around the clock oh
they're protected with guns amazing by
the way this just in and this is
breaking prosecutors now say that the
terrorists suspect asked to hang an Isis
flag in his hospital room number two
prosecutors say the terrorist suspect
said he felt good about killing innocent
people so you look at people like the
mayor of New York the governor of New
York
massive hypocrites they are accusing
president Trump of politicizing the
tragedy which is exactly what they just
did earlier today and here's the other
thing
what does gun control have to do with
this the jihadists used a pickup truck
he didn't have real guns and we know
that even the strictest gun law wouldn't
have stopped the terrorists now just
take a look at what happened in Paris in
2015 remember Paris has some of the
toughest gun laws in the world and it
didn't matter jihad is still slaughtered
over a hundred and twenty five people so
the Blasio Cuomo they don't know what
they're talking about they're completely
wrong about what it's going to take to
keep the American people safe they again
they've got armed guards and as a result
of their liberal policies of reminding
the governor reminding the mayor they
all want to be so inclusive accepting of
refugees unvetted immigrants about their
comments about conservatives in New York
remember Governor Cuomo because I had
governor's from all over the country
inviting me to live in their states
which by the way don't have a ten
percent state income tax after you said
this about anybody that's on the other
side politically than you let's remind
people their problem is not me and the
Democrats their problem is themselves
who are they are they these extreme
conservatives who are right to life
Perot
assault weapon anti-gay is that who they
are because if that's who they are and
if they are the extreme conservatives
they have no place in the state of New
York so this was that's not who New
Yorkers are well wait a minute I'm
pro-life I believe in the Second
Amendment it's clear what our founders
and framers want and Governor Cuomo I'm
the one that's saying that maybe if you
come from a country that kills people
for who they are being gay and lesbian
they're being thrown off buildings and
people then want to they grow up with
those values they want to come here to
America it tells you all you need to
know about Governor Cuomo by the way he
thinks he's gonna be President one day
here's the bottom line tonight America's
safety is at stake tonight
these policies pushed by the likes of
Schumer and Cuomo and de Blasio they are
putting all of us in harm's way